llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
en el estudio daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida y comenzamos en europa porque
van a ensayar un euro digital que tal
raúl pues mire el banco central europeo
dio luz verde a una fase de
investigación de dos años para crear la
tan esperada por muchos versión digital
de su moneda sería algo así como una
billetera digital que los ciudadanos
pueden guardar en el banco este proyecto
forma parte de una campaña de los bancos
centrales para satisfacer la creciente
demanda de medios de pago electrónicos y
abordar el auge de las riesgosas cripto
monedas que amenazan con sustituir el
negocio principal de los bancos
centrales entre los retos de las monedas
digitales todos sabemos que también
están pues o se están analizando en
países como china o eeuu tienen que ver
principalmente con que podrían facilitar
el lavado de activos o la evasión fiscal
y el gobierno de colombia presentó una
nueva versión de la reforma tributaria
recordemos que el proyecto anterior fue
el detonante de semanas enteras de
protestas que dejaron varios muertos y
le costó su puesto también al entonces
ministro de hacienda alberto
carrasquilla el nuevo proyecto que será
erradicado el 20 de julio busca recaudar
unos 4 mil millones de dólares menos que
el de antes y promete no tocar a la
clase media de hecho dice que el 60% de
la carga tributaria vendrá del sector
empresarial para este último habrá un
incremento en el impuesto de renta de
cinco puntos porcentuales y buscará un
ahorro de 500 millones de dólares en el
gasto público propuestas tan polémicas
como un posible aumento del impuesto al
valor agregado o el alza del impuesto de
renta para personas naturales no serán
incluidas según el gobierno de guandú
que vamos a ver qué pasa entonces
daniela cambiamos ahora información
porque sube el salario mínimo de
empresas privadas en la república
dominicana así es raúl hubo un acuerdo
entre gobierno empresas y sindicatos en
el marco de las conversaciones
salariales que se celebran cada dos años
el nivel de aumento dependerá del tamaño
de la empresa si es micro lo hará en un
11 por ciento hasta los 11 mil 900 pesos
locales
mediana subirá 59% y si la empresa es
grande lo hará en un 19% hasta lo
equivalente a 368 dólares o 21.000 pesos
el incremento aplica sólo para compañías
privadas que no tengan convenios
colectivos sectoriales por ejemplo no
incluye a los sectores de turismo son
las francas industriales o la
construcción y sri lanka puso límites a
sus importaciones por la escasez de
divisas bueno la situación es la
siguiente raúl en la falta de divisas se
produce porque el país tiene un gran
déficit comercial es decir que es más lo
que importa que lo que exporta y eso
afecta directamente su capacidad para
pagar una abultada deuda externa que
sólo este año la demanda más de 3 mil
700 millones de dólares por eso el
gobierno decidió prohibir o limitar las
importaciones de productos que van desde
químicos agrícolas hasta automóviles y
su especie básica que es la cúrcuma
pasando por otros de primera necesidad
como cepillos de dientes frutas y hasta
toallas húmedas
además puso límite a las transacciones
en dólares las clases es alta aunque no
tienen suficientes divisas para pagar
las importaciones de petróleo ya está
generando a su vez un drástico aumento
de los precios que ha hecho que sus
habitantes salgan a marchar contra las
medidas gubernamentales con indicadores
como están los mercados mundiales los
principales índices de wall street en
cerraron mixtos la sesión estuvo marcada
por declaraciones del presidente de la
reserva federal según las cuales va a
mantener sin cambios la política
económica en américa latina la bolsa de
sao paulo subió por tercera jornada y
estrena un integrante raúl smart fit la
mayor red de gimnasios de américa latina
emitió unos 460 millones de dólares en
acciones y fueron las que más se
apreciaron en la jornada de hoy con un
34,8 por ciento y para finalizar
entonces le pregunto qué nos tiene hoy
como cifra el día cabo las ganancias de
los gigantes de la banca en eeuu que
desde luego se dispararon en el primer
semestre
jaypee morgan que es el banco más grande
del país casi que triplicó sus
utilidades como también lo hizo city q
lo tenemos por otro lado a goldman sachs
que multiplicó sus ganancias por 7
mientras que wells fargo pues no es
comparable porque el año pasado registró
pérdidas en el primer semestre les fue
bastante bien a orio dar y entonces
gracias por toda la información
económica como siempre a ustedes también
gracias continúe con nosotros porque hay
mucho más para ver aquí en france 24
[Música]